[Music]
on this Saturday night some relief for
Yellowknife evacuees the re-entry plan
for residents ready to return home once
Wednesday comes start your journey back
as firefighters prepare for a major wind
event to threaten their progress
remembering Jimmy Buffett
the tributes pouring in for the late
Margaritaville singer Pride celebrations
and concerns I stay hopeful but you also
have to be realistic that there are very
real dangers the call for shows of
support as annual parades and events in
Alberta take place amid increased
tensions
displaced but determined
Ukrainian students head back to school
as the war continues what The Fall
season will bring for the country's
children
National with foreign
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
after more than two weeks of anxious
waiting Yellowknife residents have
finally gotten the message they've been
looking for starting this Wednesday some
20 thousand evacuees scattered across
multiple provinces will be able to
return home as Crews have managed to
push back wildfires impacting the
capital of the Northwest Territories
it's a big relief for many but officials
are warning things could still change as
weather continues to fuel the more than
200 wildfires burning in the territory
Mackenzie gray has our top story tonight
it's Clarity many from the Northwest
Territories have been waiting for
Wednesday September 6th at noon is our
official general public uh welcome home
ahead of yellow knives 20 000 citizens
being able to head home essential
workers will return starting Monday to
make sure key services are up and
running but operating at full capacity
could take some time really urging
people to to stay where you are where
there's full services available
supports are available and you know once
Wednesday comes start your journey back
up the town has essentially been closed
since August 16th when residents of the
territorial capital and surrounding
communities we're told to evacuate at
the time the fire was set to hit
Yellowknife days later but fortunately
for residents like Bill Braden the
Flames were held back just having that
that return date when the gates are
going to go open and we can go back uh
that's a that's a great relief Brady and
his wife Val have driven to Banff along
with their daughters and grandkids a
group of 10 in total who've chosen to
take a positive approach okay let's make
the best of this we're calling it an
evacuation we're very very fortunate to
to have family and friends who can help
us out once he gets home Braden is
looking forward to checking on his
garden and making sure his cabin's okay
the other thing we're looking forward to
uh hopefully is doing some berry picking
which is a great northern Pastime at
this time of year this situation across
great Slave Lake and hay river is more
precarious with strong winds continuing
to challenge firefighters who've been
able to hold back the Flames just 1.5
kilometers from the center of town every
time the fire worked to make an advance
we were able to pound it back with our
aircraft which were finally able to fly
as much as we wanted him to under better
visibility firefighters and aircraft
should get some assistance tomorrow
nithu as 15 millimeters of rain is
forecasted to hit Hay River all right
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa tonight thanks
Mackenzie
in British Columbia officials say there
are many challenges ahead for some of
the communities affected by the Bush
Creek East Wildfire which is still
burning in the province's shoe swap
region
the devastation is uh
I just can't believe what's out there
how hot this fire ran and how big the
track of this fire is we're planning on
this being a three to five year process
the fire has not grown for several days
now but still spans across an estimated
430 square kilometers plans are in the
works to allow people into the fire area
to see their properties before
evacuation orders are lifted more than
180 wildfires are still burning out of
control in the province with 13 of them
being considered of note some good news
though further south as a spell of good
weather has allowed officials to rescind
several evacuation orders near Kelowna
cleanup is underway in Hong Kong in
parts of southern China after typhoon
Salah made landfall overnight Fierce
winds and heavy rain left a path of
destruction in Hong Kong with Fallen
trees damaged cars and localized
flooding scattered across one of Asia's
top Financial hubs in Southeastern China
nearly 900 000 people were moved to
safety ahead of the storm however
several still needed rescuing after
Salah made landfall a second less
powerful typhoon is now forecast to make
landfall over Southeastern Taiwan
tomorrow
in the U.S President Joe Biden and first
lady Jill Biden are in Florida today to
assess the damage from Hurricane Adalia
the pair met with Florida residents
impacted by Adalia and was briefed on
recovery efforts in the state in a
political twist Joe Biden and Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis will not meet to
discuss Disaster Response plants a stark
contrast from last year when the two met
in the aftermath of hurricane Ian
Biden also released a statement
regarding the death of legendary singer
and songwriter Jimmy Buffett saying he
was a poet of paradise Buffett died
Friday night at the age of 76. his
rum-soaked songs led to a near-cult-like
following scoring more than a dozen
billboard singles a Broadway musical and
a net worth of 1 billion dollars as
Reggie chakini reports Jimmy Buffett
lived what he sang about a beach bum
lifestyle that paid off
wasted away
what about a signature cocktail best
enjoyed on the beach in the Sun that
elevated Jimmy Buffett to Icon status
[Music]
Yacht Rock sound helped to counter the
so-called Yuppie culture of the 70s but
it was 1977's Margaritaville that gave
the idea of what the low-key loafer life
felt like and would become the key
ingredient to a lifestyle far from it I
mean I've had a wonderful lucky career
one song kick-started A Billion Dollar
Empire with more than two dozen namesake
restaurants around the world along with
casinos Resorts and hotels a place for
so-called parrot heads to not quite
waste away rather embody The Escapist
ethos
all about fun and Friends born on
Christmas Day on the Mississippi Coast
James William Buffett made money busking
on the streets of New Orleans
he battled a bout of depression until
his first hit
gave him hope only a few years later
he'd find his lost Shaker of salt in the
Florida Keys strange things happen but
I'm glad as I said it's been a pretty
good song
with 43 albums under his floral shirts
it's this tune
it was inducted into the Grammy Hall of
Fame in 2016 and led to a campy and
panned Broadway show in 2018. I've
always been a fan of musical theater
since I would go with my mom his health
had been failing in recent months with
his family saying he died surrounded by
friends music and dogs and that he lived
his life like a song till the very last
breath with a legacy that will last long
after the party he once said he was the
life of
Global News
it is Pride weekend in Calgary but as
the lgbtq2 plus Community prepares to
celebrate many are doing so under a
cloud of anxiety police in the province
say they've seen an increase in protests
and hate motivated attacks this year
prompting heightened security at several
events this weekend but as Heather
urac's West explains organizers say
their best protection could be having
people turn out in strong numbers
in this small Southern Alberta Town
pride has come under attack where a
rainbow flag once flew stands only a
jagged post last weekend someone saw the
pull down it
is really
um
when you live here and like it's I could
leave and go somewhere else but my
family's here I do have friends here
this is my community a drag show was
also targeted the town's 112 year old
theater forced to close after someone
leaked a strong smelling substance onto
the floor this increasing
aggression needs to be addressed because
Fort McLeod is far from alone attacks
protests and rhetoric against the lgbtq2
plus Community has been steadily Rising
globally over the last two years the
situation considered so dangerous now in
parts of the United States the Canadian
government this week updated its travel
advisory warning members of the queer
Community against travel to certain
states which talking about in Florida
Texas
Tennessee and other places that have
explicitly targeted the LGBT community
and in particular trans and non-binary
uh people for me I I stay hopeful but
you also have to be realistic that there
are very real dangers it's all work to
create an air of anxiety in the lead up
to Calgary's Pride weekend the city says
security has been bolstered for this
year's Festival which includes the
annual parade but organizers say what's
most important is that supporters come
out in force I tell people I'm like two
allies pride is mandatory this year it's
it's your time to show the support the
allyship that the queer Community seeks
a call to action to show support for a
community increasingly
Under Siege Siege Heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
deadly clashes in Tel Aviv coming up
dozens are injured in chaos between
rival Eritrean groups
plus how a growing auto theft crisis is
driving up insurance rates
[Music]
more than a hundred people were injured
after violent clashes in Tel Aviv today
between Eritrean government supporters
and opponents
Israeli police in riot gear used stun
grenades to break up the clashes between
hundreds of Asylum Seekers from the East
African nation the violence occurred
near the Eritrean embassy at an event
aimed to Mark the 30 years of eritrea's
independence from Ethiopia human rights
groups have condemned the nation's
government of being highly repressive
more than 25 thousand eritreans are said
to be seeking asylum in Israel
back in our country there is a growing
auto theft crisis and that's prompting
some insurers to add a hefty surcharge
to the most commonly stolen vehicles and
gaviola explains how you can avoid
paying more than you need to and what's
driving this trend
the number of vehicle thefts since 2020
has exploded at an alarming rate it's a
national crisis Ontario and Quebec are
being hit the hardest largely because of
their proximity to the Eastern ports the
Insurance Bureau of Canada tells Global
News there was a billion dollars worth
of losses due to stolen vehicles last
year and that's only counting insured
Vehicles 700 million dollars in Ontario
alone and some have gone to extreme
lengths to deter thieves Vehicles became
a hot commodity in the early pandemic
years when Supply chains were snarled
and computer chips a key component in
many new makes were hard to come by
Auto thieves Target pushed to start
Vehicles which are easier to drive away
with SUVs and pickup trucks are go-to's
usually shipped overseas sometimes
stripped for parts this is not a
victimless crime this is uh this is
organized crime it's significant and uh
the problem of funding organized crime
and terrorism is really what uh is is
very concerning topping the list or the
Honda CRV Lexus RX and Ford F-150 series
comprehensive insurance premiums on
these commonly stolen cars soared
between 25 and 50 percent in the past
two years
the surcharge can be as much as 500
depending on the vehicle but there are
ways to get around that premium increase
by installing an anti-theft device like
a steering wheel lock or a tracking
device
be proactive in terms of avoiding having
your car stolen keep it parked in a
well-lit area keep contents outside of
your vehicle and don't be afraid to
switch to another insurance provider if
the price is right there's only a few
insurance companies that are surcharging
right now and so it might be in your
best interest to shop around protect
your vehicle and your pocketbook and
gaviola Global News Toronto
ahead how artificial intelligence is
changing teaching and learning in
classrooms
[Music]
with students across the country back in
class or preparing to head back after
Labor Day there's a new challenge facing
teachers this year the rise of
artificial intelligence apps like chat
GPT is opening up new avenues for
Learning and for cheating joining us
with more on how schools are handling
this shift is carsten Mundell with the
University of Alberta thank you so much
for being here and I should mention off
the top that you are leading a task
force at the University that's looking
into AI how are you seeing classes
integrating AI into the workflow for
both students and teachers
yeah so there's a few examples uh it's
great to be here uh chatting with you
um a few examples of of how our
professors are integrating uh one of
them is uh in in group work uh a fairly
common assignment or a way of of having
students uh work through a problem uh
and so if if normally a group had been
four individuals some instructors are
now having a group of three and chat GPT
becomes the fourth uh group member and
so as they're working through a problem
um they're Consulting with each other
but also Consulting with chat GPT and
reflecting on chat gpt's answers how
relevant it might be and and what kind
of modifications they might want to make
another example uh Professor uh
colleague of mine is teaching a really
large anthropology class and looking at
social issues Uh current issues and
anthropology and the students will be
putting some of those issues into chat
GPT and then having a conversation a
form of oral exam with a professor as a
way of again having them demonstrate
critical thinking uh and their
understanding of the course material
okay so it sounds pretty useful in those
settings what kind of concerns if any do
you have about the use of AI in
classrooms especially around cheating or
even effective learning
yeah absolutely so I know that uh
cheating is certainly a concern that
that lots of folks raise I'm very
confident in the way forward
um um our task force is made up not only
of exports from across uh the university
a variety of disciplines but also of
students
um and I think together we're really
trying to think through how do we
navigate this this technological change
uh we've done it before with tools like
calculators or applications like
Wikipedia and so I think we are really
able to imagine that by making
adjustments to our assignments by making
adjustments to how students are able to
demonstrate that they've learned the
things we're trying to teach because I
think by and large the vast majority of
our students are not setting out to
cheat and we're still finding our way
through what does it mean this this new
new technology and and what does it mean
for learning
um and how do we continue to Foster
things like writing crucial skills for
all of our graduates high school or
university how we Foster as skills like
like critical thinking so absolutely
excited about the conversations that we
continue to have with with our schools
and you mentioned those past disruptors
like Wikipedia and before that there
were calculators how do you think ai's
impact on the classroom compares to
those and do you think AI use needs to
be monitored or regulated more formally
I think regulation is really challenging
actually uh given given where it's at it
is out and out in the wild at this point
um so what we've been really focusing on
is uh AI literacy and so helping our
students understand uh and and faculty
and staff how this technology Works
um again U of A has a lot of experts uh
in helping us understand how large
language models are built
um the sort of underlying math
um that this isn't thinking the way
which you and I might do as humans we
would think this is just math and then
talking about sort of social and
political and ethical and and privacy
implications of
um of generative AI
um what about intellectual property what
about writing in the style of pick your
favorite author what are what is what
does that mean
um and then what kind of tasks should
generative AI be doing and perhaps what
tasks should generative AI not be doing
I think those are the kinds of pieces
and then thinking about how this applies
to to our learning environments
important questions there we'll continue
following your work on this issue again
that is Carson Mandel with the
University of Alberta thank you so much
thank you
next the war disrupts but doesn't
destroy back to school for these
Ukrainian students
[Music]
according to UNICEF more than 1300
schools in Ukraine have been destroyed
since Russia's full-scale Invasion began
so with the day of knowledge marking the
start of Ukraine's new school year
millions of students are once again
learning online but as we reported
earlier in the week on global news those
in hardkeve can also study in the city's
Metro System where underground
classrooms have been built Crystal
gomancing spoke with harkeeb's mayor
about what the fall will bring for the
city and the country's children
dressed up and eager for school this
level of Joy doesn't come often in
Frontline cities like harquiv
mayor ihor tarahof rang the school bell
deep underground in the Metro signaling
the start of the academic year he tells
Global News it's his obligation to give
parents and students an in-person
learning option that is as safe as
possible
yes it is very difficult actually for
children for the families this will help
them emotionally you know to to stand
with with this situation which we now
have the situation is a war in which
children have endured nearly daily
rocket and missile strikes and stolen
time with the men in their lives who are
now on the front lines but here a couple
of times a week young students in grades
one to three will get a taste of school
life
is excited and talks about his backpack
which has Donuts painted on it he says
it's empty but he'll put stuff in it
soon
president vlodimir zielinski beamed as
he chatted with school kids for more
than 20 regions across Ukraine and
Beyond wishing them a successful school
year he highlighted a newly created
Ukrainian educational app Maria which
translates into dream allows parents
teachers and students in Ukraine or
living abroad to access lesson plans and
share feedback
as the war rages on he knows it's not
possible for all kids to be back in
classrooms full-time but it is the dream
she knows what Zoom is says this mom I
want her to know what school is what a
desk is
for those in Canada embarking on a new
school year a message from harkee's
mayor
um
that they will have a really great
Academic Year and I would like to say
that thankfully Canadians children and
ukrainians Children and Families which
are moved to the Canada they have an
opportunity to teaching in the schools
in the safety in the comfortable
conditions something he hopes will again
soon be part of life in Harkey
Global News London
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm nitu garcha tonight's
your Canada is tupperville Nova Scotia
we love seeing your Canada please keep
emailing your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks so much for
watching hope you'll join us again
tomorrow have a great night
thank you